[Music]
prolapse gone sexual
she cried yeah emotional emotional
what what book are you reading right now
we never talked about it we didn't what
first of all what type of books do you
enjoy like are you a fictional guy or do
you like a like a oh you know dabble in
a little fiction we love books that pop
up
[Laughter]
I love that
the ones with the little finger puppets
in them yeah oh yeah ones that make
sounds too yeah oh that's awesome like
you click my LeapFrog has so many books
yeah
my LeapFrog Kindle IMAX Pro yeah no
that's what people think on Torah coding
or just on our Leapfrogs
she's playing shapes and doing ABCs
yeah now what is your favorite book
right now you know my favorite book I
read last year was called the secret
history by Donna tartt get into that
[ __ ] okay very um like intelligent uh
murder mystery fiction oh okay uh
written in the 90s I want to say Donna
Tarts I mean it's been out for a while
but it recently caught popularity again
on Tick Tock and it was aren't like one
of the best books I've ever written and
yes ridden ridden I I was I almost put
that slide because I was like did she
just say she wrote it yeah hey cut that
one of the best jokes one of the best
books I've ever written yeah and I did
write it no it was a variant I mean it's
been a long time since I've read a book
and I've had to like have my dictionary
app open
is that what we had to do for this one
yeah oh wow it's a very I mean like
words I've never heard of oh like what
name one oh you like big words name one
name five hey how about this lugubrious
okay [ __ ] the [ __ ] is that what does
that mean I have no idea I don't know
lugubrious got it yep to say sad
that's a stupid ass word I was
lugubriousness
sad okay me when I'm lagoob lugubrious
yes
is that you saying that yes
so much
lugubrious ow
yeah I really enjoy secret history and
um
I read I was into this like dark
Academia thing because secret history is
that it's like based at a kind of like a
Ivy League school in New England and
they kill one of their friends and
that's on the first step the first uh
page
and then the rest of the book is them
kind of like a lot of character
development whatever very very good then
I got on this kick of reading a bunch of
other dark Academia books and they were
just awful what's dark Academia a lot
like based in an Ivy League school it's
a lot of like libraries and plaid skirts
and got it you said what Harry Potter
literally yeah I would say Harry
Potter's fictional dark Academia
damn I really enjoyed that I'm reading
um this is for the girls this is you're
welcome because I'm bringing the girls
to your show okay a court of thorns and
Roses it's a series by uh Sarah J Maas
incredible it's like it's fairy porn I
was about to say it's about just some
[ __ ] let's look up the cover and I
think yeah it's fairy porn never judge a
book
it's great it's what it's just fairies
[ __ ] yeah it's just 400 pages of
people getting nailed it's porn with
okay essentially
yeah what do you guys know about fan
fiction
we we've always just kept it at arm's
length we know we know about ours yeah
what is her opinion of Cody novel oh
there is Cody Noelle fanfic y'all are
all over Wattpad and Tumblr yeah yeah I
mean it used to be
a lot you know yeah I mean oh let's go
[Laughter]
that sounds like a disease
but she went to Urgent Care and got her
choice
holy [ __ ] yeah why do you think the
ladies like literature porn because uh
video porn is [ __ ] awful I mean yeah
I actually agree with that but there's
your answer yeah it's because literature
porn is imaginative it's imaginative
it's romantic it's the female fantasy
no it's it's way better to read about a
prolapse exactly yeah because you can
imagine it you can describe it with big
words yeah exactly pewter lugubrious
prolapse yeah exactly it was a
lugubrious prolapse small
small in diameter she was known for
crowning much larger but she was
embarrassed
yeah let's go his prolapsed pulsating
with desire it's okay there's so many I
mean
I've talked about this ad nauseam on the
internet because like this is my niche
of the internet how what does that say
about me by the way but like I grew up
reading fan fiction uh that one on top
actually to be exact the Cody and Noel
one have you read that one before no oh
okay
what's the first you should read it
what's the first one sure we can read it
if it's not too like you know explicit
what's it called I want to be a cowboy
baby read it out yeah no I'm good
you just don't get it
you guys don't get it yeah
yeah we'll we'll talk about such a good
thing I don't know how to read
yeah pretty convenient right now you
have no clue I'm unbothered right now
the thing about the thing about fan
fiction is that it's that it's like it
is so romantic in ways that porn can
never be because porn is directed by men
mostly and it's for the male gays right
and so this is against g-a-y-s right
yeah
one laughing if you directed a porn how
would you do it differently there'd be
fairies
so you just make them dress up yeah same
[ __ ] yes it's beautiful
thing no and then the angles just
pointed up yeah yeah it's just the dude
on top yeah you like that [ __ ] yeah I'm
a [ __ ] elf say it more like a fairy
he's just dressed like Mr Thomas
I'm like this this is great
[Laughter]
is he playing a flute too yeah he Nays
when he's done right
okay so what's the best fan fiction
well this is uh this is one about Maddie
Healy well listen to this here's two
factoids you didn't know
uh 50 Shades of Gray was originally a
Twilight fan fiction okay and uh there's
a movie called after which was like
number one in teen romance whatever
um on in the theaters after this is a
Harry Styles fan fiction that someone
bought the rights to changed the name to
like from Harry Styles to harden
something and this was in theaters and
there are sequels wow so it's like a
profitable franchise and they removed
Harry from it entirely I'm sure his team
sent so many like cease and desists and
it's like a profitable series
so they somebody bought the rights to
the story so that the author didn't get
any royalties from the movies well I she
probably did I mean she was probably
involved in the production of it her
name's Anna Todd and they found it on
Wattpad or what Wattpad this when I was
in high school this had I'm not kidding
like 800 million reads like this 100
million and then there was a sequel and
that had you know like it was I remember
reading this as she was updating it dude
like she was we would wait for her to
upload the next chapter and then for it
to go from that but she's also kind of a
piece of [ __ ] she's very scary
the authors like good Idols uh whatever
's Idol
how would you define her then
sure Legend okay all right yeah yeah if
you change culture forever for the girls
yeah for sure anyway sorry I interrupted
you go ahead well that is I mean she
sold it and I think she had some hand in
the production of the movies and uh it
was bad I couldn't guess
um yeah what what was the movie oh it
wasn't yeah because the and the plot is
[ __ ] up anyway but it was like oh my
God and then they made the movie and it
was like this isn't obviously the Allure
was it's about Harry and so you're
imagining Harry and so with this other
guy I was like what and he's doing a bad
British accent uh she just did Regular
porn so did people like that write
Wattpad stories that get 800 million
views do they make money no they don't
it's all free in the olden days no now
there's [ __ ] ads on Wattpad yeah so
it's changed now okay but back in the
day no hey guys there can't be any curse
words in the first 20 words
nothing literally
sorry the hook and then Harry Styles
came in and he said hello hello hello
hello hello
until it's 30 words in and then what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I have never
um big British [ __ ] I've learned so much
about in my early like obviously as a
child like reading this ship learned so
much about all the different ways you
can refer to a penis
member [ __ ] throbbing Johnson that's
only three
and you struggle to find the third one I
thought you were
struggle but at the end there yeah I
thought you liked words
well these words aren't in secret
history right right right right
throbbing member here we go phallus
there really aren't many no they have to
be fan
fiction we haven't said weighing in a
long time
pull my wang no bro prick prick
referring to your dick is mean dude yeah
my little print yeah yeah yeah yeah
nothing sexy about that yeah that's like
when uh people make fun of small breasts
and they say bee stings the same [ __ ]
right there mosquito bites I've never
heard bee stings yeah yeah did people
write fan fiction ever to be repulsive
like that
probably look about y'all yeah yeah it's
probably just like the most visceral
imagery you could have ever conjure up
yeah yeah yeah schlong schlong's good
that's a good one schmider
um
[Laughter]
she's stroking on my schmeeter yeah she
meters my favorite
because you're like is it bigger is it
small oh this is a schmitter yeah is it
is it good you know
what who's the first person to say dong
well like what year do you think they
said dong dong
all right based on that voice 1910.
[Laughter]
dong dong
dang it's the it's because we've heard
it in films we think of it as like crass
like [ __ ] dong but when it's all
English and distinguished like that his
dong
please Lord yeah the male anatomy yeah
yeah yeah
please Lord pull out your dong
I do think that weighing and Dong
they're like Legacy words for yeah penis
what about plonker plonker plonker's not
a dick a plonker's like a [ __ ] idiot
and British